.
IN THE MEANTIME, SEAN HANNITY
TAKES OVER FOR THE HOUR.
>> Sean: WELCOME BACK.
AND THANK YOU.
AND WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
>> ABANDONED BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
10:30.
>> Sean: ADDITIONALLY DAY 30
OF AMERICANS HELD HOSTAGE.
THEY WERE ABANDONED BY JOE JOE N
BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
THEY ARE STILL TRAPPED BEHIND
ENEMY LINES BE IT HOSTAGE TO THE
TALIBAN.
WE STILL CANNOT GET AN EXACT
NUMBER WHICH IN AN OP ITSELF IS
A TIGRE'S.
AND LIKELY HUNDREDS OF AMERICANS
AND MORE WHEN YOU START
INCLUDING THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
OUR FELLOW CITIZENS HOPELESSLY
TRAPPED IN AFGHANISTAN ALONG
WITH THOUSANDS OF GREEN CARD
HOLDERS, THOUSANDS MORE WITH
SPECIAL IMMIGRATION VISAS, AND
OUR AFGHAN ALLIES.
THEY KNOW WILL BE SENTENCED TO
DEATH ONE AFTER ANOTHER.
IT HAS ALREADY BEGUN.
THEY'RE ALL NOW AT OF THE
TALIBAN.
ACCORDING TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THEY ARE
VERY BUSINESSLIKE AND VERY
PROFESSIONAL.
AND OF COURSE, NOTHING CAN BE
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
THEY ARE EVIL MURDERING,
TERRORISTS WHO KNOW CONTROL THE
FATE OF SCORES OF AMERICANS AND
HER ALLIES FOR 20 YEARS THAT WE
MADE A PROMISE TO THAT WE WOULD
GET AMOUNT IF THIS MOMENT EVER
CAME.
YOU ABANDON THEM.
AS WE SPEAK, TALIBAN DEATH
SQUADS ARE NOW GOING DOOR TO
DOOR.
THEIR HUNTING THEIR POLITICAL
ENEMIES AND ANYONE WITH ANY TIES
TO AMERICA OR THE WEST.
AND ACCORDING TO THE TIMES OF
LONDON, AT LEAST FOR AMERICAN
TRAINED ANTITERRORISM AGENTS
WERE TORTURED, MURDERED BY THESE
DEATH SQUADS.
ONE VICTIM HAD ALL OF HIS
FINGERNAILS PULLED OUT BEFORE
THEY SHOT HIM IN THE HEAD.
HOW IS THAT FOR PROFESSIONAL AND
BUSINESSLIKE, JOE AND
TONY BLINKEN AND JEN PSAKI?
THIS UPDATED IMAGE POSTED TO
SOCIAL MEDIA ABOUT A WEEK AGO.
WE HAVE NOT VERIFIED IT, BUT IT
SHOWS THE TALIBAN BEHEADING AN
AFGHAN SOLDIER.
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER," THEY HAVE
THE VIDEO.
WE HAVE THIS PICTURE.
VERY PROFESSIONAL AND
BUSINESSLIKE, RIGHT, JOE?
NO OTHER VIDEOS NOT YET VERIFIED
BY FOX SHOW TALIBAN TERRORIST
NOW.
WE DO HAVE USE OF THEM WHIPPING
AND BEATING WOMEN NOW ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS HAPPENING DAILY NOW AND
WITH REGULARITY UNDER TALIBAN
RULE.
IT IS ILLEGAL FOR WOMEN TO
PROTEST.
IT IS ILLEGAL FOR WOMEN TO HOLD
CERTAIN JOBS.
IT IS ILLEGAL FOR WOMEN TO SHOW
ANY OF THEIR FACE IN PUBLIC.
WOMEN ARE NOW SEGREGATED IN
SCHOOLS AND THERE ARE REPORTS OF
YOUNG GIRLS RIPPED AWAY FROM
THEIR MOMS AND DADS AND FORCED
TO MARRY TALIBAN FIGHTERS AND
BECOMES LIKE OR BECOMES LIKE.
THERE ARE TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS ON
WOMEN.
CLOTHING RESTRICTIONS.
SCHOOLING, WORK RESTRICTIONS.
BREAKING ANY RULE RESENTS OHMIC
RESULTS IN WHIPPING AND BEATING
OR DEATH.
AND LISTEN TO THIS GUT WRENCHING
VIDEO AS EVIDENCE.
[SCREAMING]
BEATING A WOMAN WHO IS SCREAMING
PROFESSIONAL AND BUSINESSLIKE?
WHAT ARE MY JOE, ARE YOU
WATCHING?
CLEARLY AFGHANISTAN IS HELL ON
EARTH FOR ALL THE WOMEN AND ALL
ARE NOMADIC OTHERS, PARADISE FOR
THE WORLD'S MOST BRUTAL
TERRORISTS.
ACCORDING TO OBAMA'S OWN
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE AND FORMER
CIA DIRECTOR OHMIC DIRECTOR,
THIS COUNTRY IS A SAFE HAVEN FOR
AL QAEDA, I SAYS, ISIS K AND
OTHER TERROR GROUPS.
AND AS FOR THE OVER HORIZON
ANTI-TERROR STRATEGY THAT
JOE BIDEN IS NOW BRAGGING ABOUT,
ALSO BRAGGING ABOUT HAVING
LEVERAGE THAT HE HAS NONE, IT'S
NOT GOING SO WELL.
LOOK AT THIS INVESTIGATION FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
WOW.
EVEN LAME SQUIRREL GETS THE
ACORN.
A RECENT DRONE STRIKE, THE ONE
DATE BRAGGED ABOUT ABOUT BUT
WOULDN'T TELL US WHO GOT HIT,
THAT TARGETED AN IMMINENT THREAT
UNDER THE EXPLOSIVES?
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ARE NOW
SAYING THAT THEY KILLED AN
UNARMED HUMAN RIGHTS WORKER AND
SEVEN CHILDREN.
JOE, YOU DID THAT.
AMERICA'S NOMADIC AMERICANS IN
HER ALLIES LEFT BEHIND.
13 SOLDIERS MURDERED AND NOW WE
ARE TAKING AID WORKERS AND YOUNG
CHILDREN AND JOE KILLED THEM.
IMAGINE IF IT WAS DONALD TRUMP.
THE TERRORIST SAFE HAVEN, 20
YEARS AFTER 9/11, BIDEN
SPINELESS, IMPOTENT ACTIONS
AROUND THE WITHDRAWAL HAD BEEN
SO BAD THAT
>> YOU'RE A -- FOR WHAT YOU DID
TO AFGHANISTAN.
TERRIBLE.
>> Sean: WEAK, FEEBLE,
COGNITIVE MASS.
NOTICE THAT JOE IS WALKING IN
WITH BILL CLINTON AND
BARACK OBAMA IN ORDER TO LOOK
MORE CREDIBLE.
THIS WEAK AND PATHETIC AS HE
REALLY IS.
BUT IT REALLY DOESN'T MATTER,
DOES IT?
BECAUSE EVERYONE ON EARTH, ALL
OF OUR ENEMIES, ALL OF OUR
ALLIES, EVERYONE KNOWS, VERY FEW
PEOPLE HAVE THE COURAGE TO JUST
SAY I, JOE BIDEN IS COMPLETELY
AND TOTALLY INEPT AND OUT OF IT.
THEY KNOW HIS CLUELESS SECRETARY
OF STATE IS NOT MUCH BETTER.
TONY BLINKEN TODAY DIDN'T EVEN
HAVE THE COURTESY OF GOING
BEFORE CONGRESS, WALKING TO GO
BLOCKS AND ANNOUNCED THAT HE
EXPECTS THE TERRORISTS AND THE
TALIBAN, THE PROFESSIONAL AND
BUSINESSLIKE TALIBAN, TO UPHOLD
THEIR COMMITMENTS ON
COUNTERTERRORISM AND RESPECT THE
BASIC RIGHTS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS
JUST LIKE LAST WEEK HE WAS
LECTURING THEM ON WOKENESS AND
INCLUSIVITY.
HOW DUMB IS THIS MAN?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE EXPECT THEM TO ENSURE
FREEDOM OF TRAVEL, TO MAKE GOOD
ON HIS COMMITMENTS ON
COUNTERTERRORISM.
TO UPHOLD THE BASIC RIGHTS OF
THE AFGHAN PEOPLE INCLUDING
WOMEN, GIRLS, AND MINORITIES.
TO NAME A BROADLY REPRESENTATIVE
PERMANENT GOVERNMENT -- --
>> Sean: WHERE IS MIKE POMPEO
WHERE WE NEED HIM?
HE IS SO TOTALLY AND COMPLETELY
AND UTTERLY CLUELESS IT MAKES
NEVILLE CHAMBERLAIN LOOK LIKE
PATTON IN COMPARISON.
HE IS THAT DUMB AND A COMPLETE
FOOL.
NO CLUE ABOUT THE REAL WORLD.
NO CLUE OR UNDERSTANDING AT ALL
ABOUT THE ENEMY THAT IS THE
TALIBAN.
THEY ARE OUR ENEMY.
THEY ARE TERRORIST.
HOW DUMB ARE YOU?
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE FOR ONE
PERSON TO BE THAT STUPID?
HE EXPECTS TERRORIST TO UPHOLD
THEIR ANTITERRORISM COMMITMENTS,
LECTURES THEM ON WOKENESS,
INCLUSIVENESS, EXPECTS THE
SHARIA LOVING TALIBAN TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS,
YOU'RE NOT WATCHING THE VIDEOS,
TONY?
NOT SEEING ANY OF THE BEATINGS
WE ARE SHOWING ALMOST NIGHTLY?
AND TODAY, BLINKEN WAS NOT GIVEN
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
HE WAS ACTUALLY GIVEN THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT BECAUSE THE
TALIBAN AS HE WAS BUSY TRASHING
DONALD TRUMP, THE SAME
DONALD TRUMP WHO BEFORE THEY HAD
ANY NEGOTIATIONS SAID I WILL
OBLITERATE YOU IF YOU DON'T
FOLLOW EVERY DOTTED I AND CROSS
T.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW METICULOUS WAS THE
PLANNING FOR THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DECLARED ON THE
MAY 1ST WITHDRAWAL?
>> THANK YOU.
WE INHERITED A DEADLINE.
WE DID NOT INHERIT A PLAN.
>> SO NO PLAN AT ALL?
IT'S AMAZING THAT IT WASN'T
MUCH, MUCH WORSE.
>> Sean: ALSO INHERITED SECURE
BORDERS, ENERGY INDEPENDENCE,
AND A GOOD ECONOMY THAT WAS
BOUNCING BACK.
ANY RACE COVID CASES BY 300
NOMADIC DURING A PERCENT
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR.
NO PROBLEM RUINING THE GOOD
POLICIES OF DONALD TRUMP BUT NOW
THAT IT'S CONVENIENT, HE WENT TO
BLAME TRUMP THAT YOU DIDN'T
OBLITERATE THEM THE WAY HE WOULD
HAVE HAD?
THIS IS THE OPIUM SEASON OR THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BLEW RIGHT
THROUGH THE DEADLINE.
BLINKEN WAS LYING AS THE WORLD
WATCH THE TALIBAN ON THE MOVE,
THEY DID NOTHING.
WHEN THEY HAD FULL SAFETY AND
SECURITY IN KABUL, THEY COULD'VE
EXTRACTED EVERY AMERICAN AND
EVERY AFGHAN ALLY AND EVEN THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT.
DONALD TRUMP'S PLAN, THE ONE
THAT HE HAD IN PLACE, WE WOULD
HAD TO KEEP BAGRAM AIRBASE IN
PERPETUITY AND HELD IT TALIBAN
ACCOUNTABLE BY FORCE.
IF THEY STEPPED 1 INCH OUT OF
WHERE THEY WERE ALLOWED TO STEP,
HE WOULD'VE BOMBED THEM.
IF THEY HARMED ANY AMERICAN, NOT
A SINGLE AMERICAN DIED IN 18
MONTHS IN THE LAST YEAR OF
TRUMP'S PRESIDENCY.
ANTONY BLINKEN IS LIVING AN
ALTERNATE REALITY.
IF YOU HAD ANY HONOR AT ALL, HE
DOESN'T, HE WOULD RESIGN
IMMEDIATELY.
HE SHOULD BE FIRED, IMPEACH, BUT
GUESS WHAT?
HE DOES NOT HAVE HONOR OR
DECENCY.
AND HE IS NOT BRIGHT PAIRED IN
FACT, HE DIDN'T EVEN SHOW UP TO
HIS HEARING AT CAPITOL HILL
TODAY.
INSTEAD, HE APPEARED ON WEBCAM
FROM HIS OFFICE LIKE THREE
BLOCKS AWAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. BLINKEN, ASSUMING IS NOT
CLASSIFIED, CAN HE TELL US WHERE
YOU ARE TODAY?
SPEAK OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> COULDN'T BE BOTHERED TO COME
DOWN HERE AND SEE CONGRESS.
ON THE AFGHANS CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES THAT HAVE NOT MET
THE QUALIFICATIONS FOR SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT VISA?
>> WE ARE IN THE PROCESS --
>> HOW MANY?
YOU WERE JUST THERE.
HOW MANY DID YOU BRING?
>> WE WILL HAVE BY THE END OF
THE MONTH, WE'LL HAVE BROUGHT A
TOTAL OF APPROXIMATELY 60,000.
>> THAT HAVE NOT MET THE
PROCESS?
SPEAK OF SOME OF THOSE WILL HAVE
BEEN THROUGH THE PROCESS.
>> ARE AFGHAN REFUGEES REQUIRED
TO BE VACCINATED FOR COVID
BEFORE COMING TO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
QUESTION MIKE >> THERE
VACCINATED AND THE UNITED STATES
BEFORE THEY ARE RESETTLED.
>> Sean: THEY DIDN'T VET THEM
PUSH A MARK THEY ONLY EXIST FOR
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
WE LEFT THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
BEHIND ENEMY LINES IN
AFGHANISTAN, BUT SOMEHOW
EVACUATED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
OTHER PEOPLE WITHOUT ANY
APPROPRIATE PAPERWORK AND NO
VETTING.
AND I'M GOING
NOMADIC --
MANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
ALLOWED TO LEAVE THE WISCONSIN
MILITARY BASE COMPLETELY
UNSUPERVISED AND TRAVEL AS THEY
PLEASE.
UNVENTED.
GREAT WORK, TONY.
GREAT JOB.
MISSION ACCOMPLISHED.
JOE, WAY TO GO.
BY THE WAY, IT'S MONDAY, IN CASE
NOBODY REMINDED YOU OR GAVE YOU
A CARD.
MARK MY WORDS, THIS CRISIS WILL
HAVE LASTING CONSEQUENCES FOR
THIS COUNTRY, ONE OF THE BIGGEST
FOREIGN POLICY DEBACLES IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS GREAT REPUBLIC.
AT ONE POINT DURING THE HEARING,
A LINE OF QUESTIONING TOOK A
PRETTY UNEXPECTED TURN.
BLINKEN WAS LEFT SPEECHLESS.
WHICH ACTUALLY WAS MAY BE THE
ONLY MOMENT THAT MADE SENSE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW LONG WAS YOUR RECENT
INTERVIEW WITH THE FBI AND WAS
IT A DEPOSITION?
>> I'M SORRY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
REFERRING TO.
>> ARE YOU SAYING THAT YOU HAVE
NOT HAD A RECENT INTERVIEW WITH
FBI SINCE BECOMING SECRETARY OF
STATE?
>> I -- I'M NOT SURE WHAT YOU
ARE REFERRING TO.
>> DID THE STATE DEPARTMENT TURN
OVER DOCUMENTS TO THE FBI
RELATED TO HUNTER BIDEN AND/OR
THE BLUE STATE STRATEGIES
CORPORATION?
>> YOU WILL HAVE TO --
>> YOU HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE OF
THIS?
ARE YOU SAYING YOU HAVE NOT HAD
AN INTERVIEW WITH THE FBI
SINCE --
>> IT WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE
FOR ME TO COMMENT ON ANY LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT --
>> Sean: OH, YOU WANT TO PLEAD
THE FIFTH, TONY?
BASED ON BLINKEN'S WEIRD
ANSWERS, I GUESS HE HAS BEEN
INTERVIEWED BY THE FBI.
JUST A GUESS.
ABOUT HUNTER AND BIDEN'S FAMILY
AND THEIR INTERNATIONAL
MONEYMAKING SCHEME.
THE SYNDICATE.
VERY SERIOUS.
THE PRESIDENT OF TH